harvard she's going to talk to us about
a new perspective
thanks so much to the organizers for the
invitation to speak here and
thanks to the amazing talks and
tutorials the last few days i've
certainly learned a lot so i'm going to
talk about causal inference it's a topic
that has not been touched upon that much
in this workshop yet and it doesn't seem
directly related to deep learning theory
but it isn't first this is an area that
has picked the interests of
researchers across various communities
statistics econometrics machine learning
computer science and so on and second
it's also an area which actually
provides us interesting questions of
statistical inference with which machine
learning can interact quite a bit
and you'll see at the end of my talk
what i mean exactly by that
so this is joint work
with three wonderful collaborators
he's currently a second year graduates i
mean finishing second year rising third
year grad student in harvard stats and
it's been really amazing working with
him he has infinite amount of energy so
i think people who work on causal
inference would probably agree that it's
generally a very hard problem and causal
inference and high dimensions is okay
that's even harder but at some point we
were stuck with sort of pages and pages
of math and it was really like one house
persistence that saw us through so
really kudos to him for uh
this uh collaboration experience rajesh
mkhirji he's currently a faculty
assistant professor in the harvard
school of public health and the great
collaborator and shiva who's in the
audience and many of you know him he's
also in harvard sets
okay so the problem for today's talk is
uh causal inference from observational
studies i will not assume much
background on causal inference from the
audience so i'll try to give a short
tutorial at the end to make sure
everybody's following along but
this is also my first paper and positive
inference so their errors in the
tutorial i'm not the person from you you
should be getting the tutorial so that's
just fyi
and our main goal
uh our end goal is to sort of understand
these problems
in settings which we can call high
dimensional uh
without uh strong structural assumptions
and underlying signals specifically
we're trying to move away from sparsity
assumptions so your signals could be
sparse or dense you just don't know and
so we are trying to build theory and
methods in these settings that's the end
goal and in this talk we'll sort of take
some of the first steps towards that
goal
okay so there is one main result in this
talk it's a new central theorem
so once i present that you'll see it's
so some nice estimator is written
consistent as a statically normal it's
all about characterizing the variance so
you can go to sleep after that that's
that's like the main result
and i will say some insights into our
proof techniques and uh time permitting
but
that will merge nicely with some some of
the material ahmed was covering in his
tutorial this morning because we do use
quite some insights from the fields of
statistical physics dimension problems
and so on
all right and as i promised there'll be
something on opportunities and
applications permission
okay so what is the problem
um we are in a slightly different
setting here than the supervised
learning settings you've been seeing
through large parts of this workshop so
now we have an id samples for this talk
but
i have three kinds of variables so the y
i's
are my outcome or response variable the
xi's are my covariates and b dimension
but i have another set of variables
these are the treatment variables and
for this talk they are going to be
binary you could talk about continuous
treatments but we are going to talk
about uh binary treatments for this talk
and the main question in causal
inference is can we estimate the effect
of the treatment on the outcome so the
treatment could be whether you assigned
chemotherapy or not to somebody and you
want to understand is that is that
effective
okay but
this is a humongously challenging
problem why
because i'm talking about data i've
observed and i had no control on the
design of that experiment so the issue
here is for every unit or individual eye
you only observe the outcome
corresponding to the assigned treatment
so for any given individual you never
get to see what would have happened if
the other treatment would have been
assigned and you know among
many challenges in causal inference
that's often referred to as a
fundamental problem
and so to navigate this problem what you
need to do we need frameworks for
talking about these things and there are
many frameworks that have been proposed
over the years the framework i'm going
to work with today is the framework of
potential outcomes which is also
alternatively known as the neman ruben
causal model and
what does this causal model tell us it
basically says that let's denote
uh y i t to be the outcome we would
observe if treatment t were assigned to
individual i and i don't get to see both
of these in my data
uh but once you define these quantities
you can talk about
um how to estimate the effect of the
treatment on the outcome and how you
estimate that is by introducing various
target parameters of interest which have
some causal interpretations so the
simplest of this is the average
treatment effect which is simply
expectation of the difference of these
potential outcomes
uh you know one step up in some sense is
the conditional average treatment effect
which is this expectation but you're now
looking conditionally straighter by
straighter depending on the covariate
values and so there can be many other
such causal effect estimates that's what
we'll call these and this talk will be
about the simplest and perhaps the most
canonical one of these okay so we'll
talk about that which
0 or 1 right so for this stock i'm i'm
keeping t to be 0 yeah
okay now what's the problem as i said
you never get to observe both outcomes
for any an individual so you actually
expect this to be an imposed problem so
i cannot identify this parameter from my
observational data without further
assumptions
um so there is this entire sub area of
causal inference broadly that tries to
figure out what are what is the
structure i need on my observed data
distribution so these causal effect
estimates can be identifiable
so i'm here laying out sort of three
standard assumptions you can find this
in sort of
causal inference textbooks they have
different names depending on the branch
of causal inference you're working with
and this talk will not be about
identification so you know this is all
causal identification it's a huge huge
literature and people are stress testing
these assumptions trying to come up with
better assumptions and procedures for
testing this and so on so this is causal
identification and what it says is that
under some standard assumptions
um quantities like the at can be
identified from the data and what that
means is the following that you can
write your ate
which on the left side was you know its
functions of at least one of them is
unobservable for each individual right
you can express your a t as a function
of the observed data distribution so the
right hand side is based on conditional
distributions and marginal distributions
of your observation right
so if you can have such an
identification equation then your your
goal now we are in inference land where
you try to estimate this quantity given
the data you observe okay so
our goal today is to not think about
when this equality is true but try to
estimate this point
okay so that's what you need for
identifying this parameter
and then so now we can talk about eighty
estimation and that's a very very well
studied problem in the literature
um and there has been seminal works in
this context right but if i were to sort
of quickly summarize the flavor of these
works uh what i would need to do is
introduce two nuisance functions that
show up and what's a news is function
it's something that's not your actual
object of interest but it shows up in
the process of estimating the ate
and the first nutrient function is the
conditional distribution or the
conditional mean
of your treatment variable given the
covariates and that's called the
propensity score
and the second second nuisance function
is the conditional expectation of your
outcome variable given the treatments
and the covariates and because the
treatments are binary here i can simply
look at these two conditional
distributions individually so these are
known as our outcome regressions
so what sort of happened in this
literature is based on which one you're
modeling different approaches were
proposed uh perhaps one of the most
classical ones or inverse probability
weighting goes back to classical
literature and sample surveys and so on
um and that really tries to model the
propensity score as well
now you can flip around that view and
instead try to model the outcome
regressions well that gives you the
class of estimators known as g
computation probably
and then of course you have two nuisance
functions you can hope to talk about
how can i smartly model both of them or
borrow best of both worlds and that
falls broadly under the category of what
are known as augmented inverse
probability weighting estimators
targeted emily and so on
okay in some sense this third thread is
better in this is that it tries to
combine the rest of the portfolio so
today's talk is about this augmented ipw
a lot of you might know this estimator
under the name of double robustness or w
robust estimator
i use this term because we will be in
slightly different regime than existing
literature where it's unclear if it
still stays doubly robust or not so i
used its like original name from when
the thing was introduced in the
literature instead of using the term w
must so this estimator will study and so
just sweet just so and this is very
commonly used because it is nice
properties i'll show you that
ah but just so we're all in the same
page let me first introduce this
estimator for me
so to introduce this
aipw that's natural acronym
so what it does is it computes estimates
for these nuisance functions and then
uses a plug-in principle
seems natural
so let's denote these to be our
estimated nuisance functions you can do
you can have an estimator for each
sample because you know you have a
different x i for each of them right
and then the aipw simply difference a
difference of two terms
okay that's just math equation not
really giving us much insights right so
this is my first term this is my second
term you can see i have labeled them by
the treatment values so that should say
that this first part is corresponding to
the treatment arm
and the second part is corresponding to
the control arm and the best way to see
that is
uh ai is zero one right so if a i equals
one this term actually survives so you
see the contribution here whereas if i i
equals 1 this term vanishes so if i
equal 0 then this term survives so
so this is what's happening along each
arms but the important thing here is
there are two parts to this estimator
right
the first part is your classical inverse
probability weighting it is really
trying to model the propensity scores
and doing inverse probability weighting
and it's using nothing about the output
regressions
okay and this is the second part and now
we see the outcome regression estimators
showing up and there's a rescaling
factor which is actually very carefully
designed the rescaling factor involves
the propensity score estimates
and
this combines best of both worlds in a
sense that
when you analyze this estimator um you
look at its deviations around the true
ate then in some sense the error terms
that show up
um show up as
products of two error terms one part
comes from the propensity scores one
part comes from the outcome regression
so if you have products of two errors
then if you model one of them really
well and your error is really low you
can pay less price for the other one so
if something is really really small you
can still multiply with something a
relatively large thing so that overall
thing is really small so that's the idea
that's that's why you have sort of two
parts to this
okay so that's classical aipw for you
and i summed over all the observed
samples
okay cool
now
why is this estimator so popular it's
popular because it has this fascinating
double resonance property it's remains
consistent
i'm just talking about very classical
work here under fixed dimensions large
sample asymptotics even when one of the
models has been specified and it happens
precisely for this reason that if you
look at these deviations you get product
of two terms so you know you have some
room to play with
okay so that's
classical causal inference in ten
minutes for the background i'll need for
this talk so now we're jumping yeah
ah right right right okay thank you for
asking me that so what i did so far here
i just wrote this as conditional
expectations
right and i did not assume any model on
any of them
but in practice you could maybe model
these by parametric models or people
also do non-parametric models right so
this aipw has this nice property that um
so this if you have a model for this
that's your propensity score model if
your models for this that's your outcome
regression models and so aipw has this
nice double robustness property that
even when one of your assumed models is
wrong for one of the nuisance parameters
the estimator still remains consistent
for the ate
so it allows natural misspecifications
and that's why the form of the estimator
is really important
so you can be completely specified in
one of the nuisance models and your
eventual estimator is still consistent
okay and so i just i
said double robustness and the classical
definition is like this but actually
this estimator does more it stays root
inconsistent asymptotically normal also
when things are may specify one of them
is misspecified it's all of this kind of
understatement
okay so fast forward to the recent few
years
there has sort of been an explosion in
understanding causal inference in the
presence of high dimensional covariates
or confounders whichever way you might
call it
and of course the natural reason is
because we have a lot of high
dimensional data everywhere these days i
don't need to motivate high dimensional
data for this audience
but also there is another reason that is
often cited that is um having an
unmeasured confounder that affect
affects both your
uh treatment and uh outcome invalidates
your causal
uh statements
so if you had access to lots of
variables you would basically like to
include all of them
and that might be our one good hope to
mitigate the unmeasured confounding
issue so okay but basically point is for
a lot of reasons we need to have
valuetarian methods that allows us to do
causal inference in the presence of high
dimensional
covariates and there have been lots of
works along these lines
and broadly these works try to push the
frontier on double robustness so
there's lines of work which are known as
rate double robust and there are lines
of work which are known as model double
rust and what they do is they try to
allow different forms of
misspecifications
and sort of push the frontier on what
you can see
even when you're in very high
dimensional settings and when i say high
dimensional here most of these are sort
of
the number of variables is really really
large so ultra high dimensional much
larger than number of samples
and a common theme in this literature is
you can have number of variables to be
really really large
but whether you have
well specified or misspecified settings
at least one of your nuisance models has
to be highly sparse
okay and that's a common theme
and that's there for
for reasons that you really need it in
those regimes so okay for the
theoretical analysis and so on and so
forth so that's a common theme that
across this literature
at least one of your nuisance models
needs to have
highly sparse structures for the theory
and methods to work out
and this is sort of where we come in um
to motivate
what we're trying to do and why we're
trying to do that i'm going to show you
the simulation and to some of you in the
audience this might be familiar if
you're familiar with the high
dimensional regression literature
so here what we are doing is the
following um i have number of samples
ten thousand number of uh features is
seven hundred so it's moderate
dimensional it's not really high
dimensional in that sense
and we're just plotting a version of the
ipw and what it is that we're exactly
plotting so we're taking the fpw
estimator
empirically calculating uh
its standard deviations and doing many
replicates of this and getting histogram
of
those objects and that's the blue
histogram on the right
now if i go back to the existing
literature whether classical fixed
dimensional asymptotics or the sparse
ultra high dimensional literature in
such a setting
this is the red line
and what do i mean by such a setting so
there is a lot more that's happening in
the setting i have sort of id gaussian
designs i could change the designs to be
sub gaussian that part matters less but
the crucial thing is i have used a
linear model for my outcome regression i
have used a logistic model for my
propensity scores and the underlying
signals are iid gaussian
okay so for this simulation that means
all of the coordinates are nonzero
and the fact that all of them are
non-zero is less important even if a
positive fraction of them were non-zero
we would see something similar but there
is something about we don't have spiked
non-zeros which are really large and
everything else is zero that's not the
structure so what do we see here we see
that the true variability of the
estimator is much higher than what the
existing results tell us
and this kind of variance inflation by
now is very well understood in the
context of high dimensional regression
when you just have a vanilla regression
problem you're trying to infer
coefficients there something similar
happens that's more or less well
understood by now and in the causal
inference context formally i mean
although you expect such variance
inflation and it was alluded to in the
econ literature for several years now it
was formally pointed out in this
recently beautiful paper by stevie atlos
so what does this tell us
tells us a few things first
the existing ultra high dimensional
literature does not capture these
regimes and it can those results can
actually fail when you move away from
some of the sparsity assumptions
and two you don't even need to go very
high dimensional
to see such phenomena okay
so
our goal is to try to explain this plot
through this talk
and nothing comes for free so instead of
assumptions on the signal structure we
will have strong assumptions on the
covariate covariate distributions and
then we'll sort of discuss how much of
those can be relaxed and so on and so
forth
okay so i more or less motivated this so
what's our goal we want to analyze a
commonly used version of the ipw in a
regime that we can still say this is
arguably high dimensional in the sense
that you see pure high dimensional
effects in that regime without assuming
any sparsity type assumptions on the
underlying nuisance parameters whereas
the nuisance parameters are high
dimension
all right so there are a few parts to
this question
so the first part to this question is
understanding aipw in some regime like
this
and the moment you go to high
dimensional regimes the aipw that i
introduced before kind of doesn't work
directly
instead there are versions of that
estimator that people have come up with
which they actually work with because
the original aipw where you're computing
the estimator with all the n samples it
is actually very hard to analyze so what
i'll do next is i'll first introduce the
versions of that estimator that people
usually look at in high dimensions and
then sort of segue into
our our formal setting and then our
results
okay so what are the versions of the ipw
yeah
so when you're saying
still smaller than n but you want like
the previous results to be more
uh
capture better would happen right so i
okay so i'll hold off on that question
because
for our
for our main result that is sort of the
regime will be in but there is there are
there are lots of layers to that
question so i'll sort of slowly segue
into what i mean by that so so maybe
i'll put off answering that right now
and you should find the answer so yeah
any other questions before
okay so
first thing that happens is you have a
large number of comparatives if all your
nuisances is everything's calculated
from your full data things become
intractable and there are also other
issues that happen so
the standard thing that people do
is sample splitting
and then cross fitting so let me explain
one thing you could do
to analyze these estimators better in
high dimensions is
you split the sample into let's say
three parts you had two kind of
nuisances that you need to estimate
estimate your nuisances from two of the
folds and then you estimate your final
eipw from a separate fold okay so you
have three folds
so then you can switch the role of the
force like you know we often do that
gives you three factorial estimators and
then you can average them so this final
step where you're averaging all of this
that is called crossfitting
and there are other versions right so
for instance i can split into two folds
i'll calculate all my new sensors from
one fold the ipw from the other get two
average okay so that's version two
and something really nice that used to
happen in the earlier literature even if
when you're ultra high dimensional if
you have nice sparsity in at least one
of your new senses is
so let's focus here i before the
averaging i have three factorial
estimators
and on the root and scale what happens
in the earlier literature is the
covariances between these estimators
becomes asymptotically negligible
so what what is effectively happening is
your sample splitting to keep things
tractable but then when you average you
gain back the lost efficiency
and that's really nice and that has sort
of you know that's why you should
crossfit in reality
right
so this is sort of what happens uh in
prayer works
for our talk today we will focus on this
version
and one thing that we will see is
we don't have this nice
vanishing cross covariances anymore but
i'll make that precise so this is where
we'll focus
just so we are all on the same page i'm
sorry for repeating but sometimes it's
good to repeat to make sure that we all
know what estimator we're looking at
you're splitting into three parts
propensity scores from one part output
regressions from the other part and the
final estimator is from third part
and that gives me three factorial
estimators if i switch the rules of the
three folds we average this and that's
my final object
so what do we call this i mean we don't
need to name this but it's helpful for
the talk so it's a three split split
into three parts
uh crossfit three is pretty epic
it's not known by this name in the
literature it's just ipw is a general
estimator you can do it whichever way
you sample so but just so we know what
we're talking about
cool so
now maybe i'm slowly getting into things
that starts addressing larger's question
um what do we want to do we want to
understand this estimator going away
from sparsity assumptions right
so what are the main hurdles
first main hurdle is okay so we have
these three factorial estimators before
averaging and maybe what we want to do
is let's characterize their asymptotic
distributions pre-crossfit
but okay that's not enough because we're
crossfit so we need to understand joint
dependencies eventually but even when we
want to do this if we don't assume if we
don't want to assume much structure on
the signals up to p signals are allowed
right all of them could be nonzero
if you want to have sort of a motivating
example for this setting
such settings are known as many
instruments or many regressors in the
econometrics literature
and there are surveys written on these
kinds of settings
and so what happens is the moment i
allow this it's sort of the moment p is
going to diverge higher than small o of
n
you would start observing high
dimensional effects
in the sense that on the scale of these
orders so even if the ratio is even as p
is less than n in some sense but it's
diverging at a rate higher than this you
should already observe high differential
effects
so this is starting to get at you know
what what i'm calling high dimensional
in this scheme of things
okay and as i said just this ascendant
distribution is not enough we need to
track the joint distributions and so
suppose magically i know they're jointly
gaussian then what i need to track are
the variances and the covariances
between these
all right so we need theoretical tools
that allow us to do this and that
applies for a broad set of dense sparse
signals alike in these kinds of high
dimensional regimes
there's a whole or more than one area
that gives us such tools
they are you know they come from
statistical physics and parts of
probability and so at the end hopefully
we'll go back to some things that are
that was talking about
and just to highlight this is not very
hard what will be hard is understanding
the covariances between all of these
estimators when i don't have much signal
structure
cool so now i get into my formal setting
and
this is where
uh
like we were told to be critical of our
own work right
this is where there's a lot of things to
critique because we're trying to get it
really precise answers
uh going away from signal structure and
that comes at a cost
so the price to pay at least for this
work which also is one of the first
central limit theorems in this regime so
hopefully we can relax some of the
prices but right now not yet so the
price to pay is okay we have well
specified
models for my propensity score so these
were you know these were the treatments
so they're bernoulli with some link
function
some x i transpose beta we we did it
with the logistic link but anything else
that's like that should also work
and then we have a linear model for the
outcome regressions
and my formal high dimensional setting
is this proportional scaling regime
where the ratio between number of
features and samples is going to some
positive constant
for our theorems we will need to
restrict the ranges where this constant
can lie okay
this is the strongest assumption
for now i only have simulations to show
you that this is not the only regime
where our results work but there is a
lot of universality result that does
need to be proved in this area
to relax this
okay so we don't have sparsity structure
on the signals but we do need something
because if you don't assume anything
your signal to noise ratio can
go to zero or explode and you know you
you you would not hope to do you know in
one case the thing should become trivial
in the other case it should become too
hard
so what i'm writing here it looks in the
form of these you know
uh if i define an empirical distribution
on these
parameters that gives mass let's say 1
over p to each of these coordinates
then this is really the moments the
second moments of that empirical
distribution
but
it looks odd why this thing comes up a
better way to probably visualize this is
if i take the variance of my log odds
that's basically so that's just variance
of let's say x i transpose beta in this
first model
and this is a rescaling of that because
i have normal zero identity over it so
what i'm really doing is i'm trying to
hold the signal to noise ratios to be
finite in the limit
and this part is just saying that my two
regression models you you can't be like
wildly different from each other in some
sense
so these are you should think of these
as snr controlling the snr having
moderate snr problems and i don't want
these to be infinite
okay
um i want to comment a bit about this
regime uh you can call it whatever you
want you can call it proportional
asymptotics proportional scaling
but
there have been many many many different
areas that have been looking at this
regime
on the stat side you know
we
it started with you know johnston and
lou or maybe even earlier we have all of
the random matrix theory stuff and more
recently people have been looking at
this regime in the context of
other problems where you use tools from
um you know stat physics and probability
theory and so on
there's a whole econ literature which
does this and that is the many
instruments in many regression
regressors line of works
and in machine learning we know offset
scaling levels right uh not all of this
are in this exact setting but even when
you're taking certain scaling limits of
like how many neurons you have and how
things are growing
you you work with such scaling limits
and you see a lot of phenomena because
of you know nice scaling limits
so i didn't include any references here
because
there are a lot and these are really
sort of the areas from where a lot of
the tools um you know i at least use a
lot of the tools from so if you're
interested in the original references
here i'm happy to speak after the talk
but this has much much older roots i
mean
i mean george percy got the nobel prize
last year and he's the creator of the
cavity method that
you know one of the co-creators and
stuff
that amit talked about
okay so this is our main result
um
under sort of the assumptions that i
laid out if you estimate nuisances using
things we can nicely track i'll come
back to this
then the aipw i was interested in is as
i said we have one clt it's a root
inconsistent asymptotically normal so
what's going on why was it hard to prove
the clt because we characterized the
variance pretty com like pretty
explicitly
and one of the things you can do once
you characterize this variance is that
it clearly it's much higher than the
classical variance or the previous ultra
high dimensional literature variant so
this explains the variance inflation
plot that i was talking about
the other thing that happens is i'm
sorry it's written in these equation
forms but
this part actually has a nice uh
interpretation in that
if you look at your x i transpose betas
along the treatment arm and the control
arm and take difference of the norms of
those or like just the absolute values
you in the limit that's what you get
and you actually expected to see that
difference somewhere
okay so
that's sort of the main result
um
let's do some stress testing or
simulations
um
first it's really simulations in our
setting so what are we doing here
i'm plotting sample quantiles versus
theoretical quantiles of the ipw
estimator and so the darker blue points
correspond to our formula just from the
previous slide and this is the classical
formula which also is the same as the
sparse ultra high dimensional formula so
the variance is different for these two
parts and you can see that
in these sorts of settings it's a
similar setting as my variance inflation
but uh that was where we that was our
home ground so naturally we do better
that's not a surprise um just saying
what is this plot
um so the aipw has these propensity
scores in the denominators
and so if i use let's say logistic
models i'll get the sigmoid here so if
that becomes close to zero or one things
blow up so what people do in practice is
they just trim this object
you know
so that they're away from zero one so
this is just a bit more so on the tails
it's a bit better
okay so any questions so far
so the plot i want to spend some time on
is this one actually
so what am i doing here remember we were
looking at this aipw which
had sort of three factorial estimators i
was averaging
here i'm taking one of those estimators
and looking at its empirical standard
deviation
scaled by 1 over square root 6
because i have 6 of these i i scale that
by 1 over square root of 6. so that is
this histogram
but now i look at the crossfit aibw
which was averaging all these estimators
and that
the empirical standard deviation for
that is here
so this difference is not observed in
the broad literature
so crossfitting okay this is the setting
where the blue histogram moves to the
left so what does that suggest that
suggest that oh crossfitting buys you a
lot because if there are no covariance
terms then these would have been the
same
essentially
yeah so um
maybe i can write for this particular
plot okay
so um my aipw
crossfit
is i have sum over
i in some set there are you know three
factorial many
ipw one and you know i have these things
or just i right so there are three
factorial things
and now i'm claiming that this plot
shows at least in the setting that the
covariance between these is
non-negligible
so the right hand side is just my
standard deviation of one of these
marginally they all have the same
standard deviation
okay
scaled
and the the left hand side is is this
object
and so this is a phenomena that
surprised us because of course lots of
benefits of crossfitting have been
talked about in the literature before
and the main argument has been oh if you
sample split then cross crossfit you
recover back the last efficiency but
here it seems you actually gain more so
we were very excited about this
initially and then so now i don't want
to claim much because in some settings
we are starting to see this might also
go a bit to the right so what happens is
how you estimate your newest senses
really matters but the main phenomenon
happening here is that your cross
covariances are no longer non-zero at
the root and scale
whereas this is not something you would
observe before so it's very important
how you do your nuisance estimation
okay
okay so the other thing we were
interested to see this although we
expected this and i think you would
expect this
that is
when we use so we can use regression for
estimating the propensity scores
if we use that
and we plot as a function of uh the
tuning parameter
um the standard deviation of our
estimator then this is the plot you see
and so if you try to obtain the lambda
by optimizing for the prediction error
you would not recover this
so
i don't think that as a phenomenon
should be surprising and this we are
doing with even our cross validation
which for the prediction error should be
consistent
um so this the plot shouldn't be
surprising but what this says is we
actually need better
ways to tune our tuning parameters that
are explicitly optimized for the for the
inference properties of the estimator so
for instance
we need we need to identify this lambda
if we were to use
ridgeless or whatever
um and for that we actually need a good
estimate for the downstream variance
that shows up in our clt so that that's
something we're thinking about now we
don't yet have that but there's
something to lay out that if we just
naively optimize for prediction error we
would be far from the optimal land
so these are some of the immediate
upshots and
um you can stress test assumptions and
simulations right
um
and these are basic simulations to see
what happens if my covariates were not
gaussian but let's say they are sub
gaussian
so we did it for many settings we kind
of expect to see the same thing if you
have some gaussian tails and there are
universality results in the area that
allude such things would happen so this
is just for a uniform you see a similar
plot and this is
for a discrete distribution when uh your
covariate values are um
um supported on zero one and two
but that's not a proof okay so there
there is a long way to go in terms of
how much we can relax the assumptions on
the ovary distributions
okay so
how am i doing on time
okay sure
okay so
now what i want to talk about a bit is
uh about the proof techniques
because one thing that happened was
slightly to my surprise i've worked on
this professional syntax area quite a
bit before but one thing that happened
here was
we needed
a few different proof techniques and
then we needed to put them together
as sort of
pieces of a big jigsaw puzzle and that
was a bit of a surprise
um so one of the techniques we use a lot
is this lever now technique which is
alternatively known as cavity method in
statistical physics
it has really old roots in that
literature and
if you're interested to study this in
the context of let's say statistics
regression problems then a really nice
short reference is
this uh paper
uh by elka ruiz at all in the
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences so there they actually did it
for linear models and it the derivation
is really short and it's nice to read in
the sense that usually cavity method
papers
are pretty long
but this because this was six pages i
learned the stuff from there so i
strongly recommend you have to learn
this this is actually a very good
reference
uh if you're interested in like glms and
stuff then you can look at some of my
earlier works and then there are also
more recent works uh on spectral methods
and stuff by uh chennai told it's a
really nice survey
okay so that's one of the techniques
the other technique we used is this
whole sort of
zoo of things known as approximate
message passing theory and ahmed
presented that quite a bit for one of
the one of the models
and what this does is okay so what does
lever now do its main goal is to help
you decorate dependencies in various
terms at least for my purposes that's
what it does
and what does amp do uh for my purposes
it has other uses but i usually use it
as a proof technique so
it basically helps track properties of
estimators in models where you don't
have closed forms for your estimator so
whenever you don't have closed forms
things become hard to track at least in
the proportional regime you can't do
random matrix theory stuff
with some recent developments maybe you
can in some cases but
in a lot of cases you can't and that's
where this sort of tool comes in
um
and then we actually also needed
something known as deterministic
equivalence from the random matrix
theory literature and this helps track
quadratic forms of random matrices by
connecting to more tractable
deterministic matrices
so what i want to do in the next few
minutes is
try to give a crash course on these two
and sort of show a bit
how these show up and why these are
important for understanding certain
models and statistics
okay so this is a very quick peek into
leave one out in our setting
now
to describe this i have to remind you
that
what was our crossfit aipw like
the ipw had many terms but
without crossfitting it had something
like
a i y i by propensity score estimates
so if i assume a logistic model let's
say my estimates look like the sigmoid
applied to x i transpose let's say some
beta hat and our theorem was for the
ridge regression
okay
so
these terms show up
there are many other terms
but the important thing is that
for the crossfit estimator i'll have
these terms when my eyes let's say
let's say i is in the first split
and
the corresponding beta hat could be from
any of the other splits so that's nice
because those are independent right
but in the crossfit estimator when i'm
averaging three factorial quantities
somewhere i have all the eyes from s sub
a
and somewhere else in the estimator i
have the beta hat from that same fold
so there are lots of dependencies
and so what the leave one out
allows you to do is
you you get something like
you get something like x i transpose
uh beta hat let's say this is from s sub
c and this is from s sub a
and then somewhere else i have from
s sub a and
um you know j could be
let's say let's just switch
so what it allows you to do it's it
starts helping you to decouple things
so what i could do is
let's say for simplicity this is from s
sub b this is for simplicity but we will
get more complicated terms too so my
dependency here is arising because of
the x i from s sub a and this from s sub
a
but the nice thing is
you can calculate the same estimator by
leaving out the ip
observation right
and
that gives me
except you
incur an error
because of this approximation
so you have to track this error
so this slide is a is a i don't know
it's a not so good attempt at trying to
say exactly this step that is what we do
is we connect your beta hat s a to the
leave one out quantity
one question you can ask is how do i
connect them uh the way you connect them
is
this satisfies
some
let's say this is my regularized
likelihood function so this is solution
to some you know this has some or so
some first order stationary conditions
and then i can leave an observation out
i get
something like this
so these arise as uh solutions to first
order stationary conditions you
basically just write them out and do
nice algebra but somebody has to teach
you like some nice paper has to teach
you how to do the algebra for the first
time okay so that algebra gives you a
relation like this where uh this object
does not depend on these observations
okay cool
that's nice because
i know a lot of stuff about these kind
of quantities
and even we observe quantities where i
have let's say the x i and a beta hat
and i drop this out so i know that these
kinds of quantities these are
independent so i basically have these to
be if i have gaussian covariance i have
gaussian with some norm square roughly
conditional on this object right
and then if you can show that this norm
object actually concentrates
um
you know you you can track this quite
well
so that's how the leave one out is
helpful it's really helping to decorate
dependencies as i said
now suppose i have to track these kinds
of norms uh let's say the underlying
model was logistic regression or
something that doesn't give me closed
forms okay um
the same level now can help you track
that that that proof becomes many more
pages long so we i don't know if we want
to do that but there is this whole other
set of tools that helps you track any
low dimensional functional of this form
uh whenever estimators don't have closed
forms and that's where your approximate
message passing comes yeah
can you say a bit louder sorry
okay that's a regression so for this
heuristic the derivation i actually
don't need any gaussian it is really
like write out your optimization
equations
and and you you get this relationship
to make things formal
you you need actually up to sub gaussian
tails
but we start needing gaussianity when
when we go to the what's the actual
distribution of the estimator and stuff
like this
so we need gaussianity downstream
improving the clt
um
well in some sense we need gaussianity
to practice things but
okay we need gaussian in many other
cases but the the concept of leave one
out is really if your system satisfies
certain stability conditions then
at least leave an observation out is is
okay
i haven't told you
what's the problem the problem is we
don't have only one out step and that's
how causal inference is different from
regression problems we have many of
these steps so these errors actually
accumulate downstream
so so that that is where sort of our
contribution was in this work but if i
were to just explain leave one out
i'm you know i can just explain it
writing out these kkt conditions
other questions
okay
so i'm going to quickly gloss over the
main steps of amp in this case it's a
big sort of machinery so we're not going
to cover it in like a few minutes but
what does this machinery allow us to do
um
what it does is basically okay so we
i said the mle but it can be something
else uh that that satisfies let's say a
first-order
condition
doesn't have a closed form how to track
in high dimension so we want to replace
it by a tractable surrogate so what what
is it that you do
the first step is you need to introduce
a suitable iterative algorithm
uh
what does suitable mean
suitable has two stages to it one
the algorithm needs to be such that we
can analyze the asymptotic behavior of
the algorithm iterates because otherwise
why am i introducing my algorithm right
like i can't study this estimator and if
i then introduce an algorithm where i
can't study the iterates that's not
helpful so i went from one intractable
problem to another right so it's a
really nice algorithmic proof technique
uh for this work where the algorithm
iterates are uh their behavior can be
tracked and that's tracked using a
formalism that has been developed in the
literature known as state evolution
in a series of beautiful papers
uh by don maluki montenari then by athen
montenari uh and in more general models
javan martin montanari uh
but that's one part of the suitable the
other part is your algorithm iterates
need to converge to your estimator of
interest in some appropriate sense
because i want to track this object
right so i went here
but then i need to come back here
and so what happens is for this first so
this first step is always the pain in
the sense that you have to understand
what algorithm you should be looking at
for your problem so you need to come up
with it this step you can rely on
existing literature once you have amp
algorithms you know you can usually cast
it in one of these forms and calculate
this behavior but this last step is
always problem specific and problems
need a lot of structure to do this
cluster
but what it gives you as an upshot is
you can track
so what you can track let me just show
here you can track norms very easily
and if you can transfer all the
information of the iterates to your
estimator you can track norms of your
estimators and that's what we needed
okay so why is this hard none of this is
actually new because mp for all these
things was was done by other people and
myself in the past it's hard for this
precise reason and i alluded to it in
answer to constantine's uh
question that is
causal entrance really uncovers novel
challenges and that's because when you
look at these estimators
you have among many other quantities all
of these
so i can be in sa or sb or sc one of the
three splits and then k k is equal to
one of the others and you need to look
at all of this simultaneously right
so leave one out helps decorate pairwise
dependencies it's always an equation
like this
and each time you use it you pay a price
so if you use if i use this leave one
out relationship n
times and i don't have errors that are
at the right order these errors are
going to accumulate
they can cumulate pretty bad
so we actually need to track many of
these dependencies simultaneously and
their terms cumulate and that requires
very careful analysis so we've had to
sort of some summarize in a nutshell
why we had sort of one result but the
proof took like 100 pages
it's because you know they start
accumulating and we didn't realize it
when we started the problem that the
crossfitting is just going to be
so sort of difficult but that's the
price you pay if you want very precise
answers
okay so what are the steps where one
could interact with machine learning we
were doing pretty naive nuisance
estimators
and note i restricted to
mle for the outcome regression
um
always
um and what's actually done in practice
following this double device machine
learning work and several others is you
you use pretty fancy modern machine
learning based methods for nuisance
estimation
and so we do not understand yet how you
know what we proved and results like
this how that interacts with if you use
more fancy nuisance estimators i mean
there are obvious road blocks in our
proof but there's also a lot that has
been understood under such scaling
limits on the machine learning side in
the last few years so maybe there is
some hope that these can be you know
meshed together nicely
okay so quick summary i showed you a clt
in an arguably high dimensional setting
for the crossfit aipw estimator this was
our goal moving away from these
assumptions comes at a price
we quantified the precise variance
inflation and something to note is if
you assume sparsity now within our stuff
you'll go back to the variance that was
before so in some sense you recovered
that in the limit but we don't have a
formal proof of that if you simulate in
various parts settings you you using our
formula you'll get back the classical
formula
okay and we see these non-trivial
crossfit covariances or covariance
between these three factorial estimators
which is certainly a new high
dimensional phenomenon which wasn't
really observed before
and so why do we care about clts because
they give us at least asymptotically
valid confidence intervals if you can
estimate the variance
and that's sort of a big question going
forward
and there are of course
too
easy to see i mean okay i don't know if
elephants in the room are easy to see
but there are two elephants in the room
and of course like how do we relax these
assumptions and how do we go to more
general nuisance estimators
and of course then what happens to other
causal effect estimators
okay so i'll finish with that thanks uh
so much for your attention
i think we have time for our questions
so when you talk about double machine
learning is it using different
estimators to
estimate those usage parameters and
getting clts using sort of maybe more
involved
was that right so so the double so what
i didn't say was this ai
is part of this double machine learning
based estimators
and so what changes there is really how
you estimate the nuisances but the
subject the
the area of the formula is the same
but
they are able to go to more fan slips
and substitutes a human structure on the
signal so there is
but in that setting you can
you can use more fancy estimators and as
long as you have some assumptions so so
they actually
learn to estimate the nuisances sort of
consistently
and then do a plugin
but something that's important is in our
regime
you currently have a consistent boost in
success you can't estimate the full p
dimensional vector consistent
but what's important is you can still
get a t estimates that are consistent
because the 80 is a low dimensional
product
so so there is a fundamental difference
between the solutions
the same number of things independently
in average
so they are both multicargo
right so the developer
just i'm plotting a different estimator
so one of them was a one of the three
factorial estimators just its
variability scaling right yeah
so the difference between the two is is
that one
each sum and it's independent of the
other it's not yeah yeah so i'm trying
to figure out why i should expect
no sorry
um
so i was trying to say through that is
none of the summons are not independent
so
let me go back okay okay
let me go back um
so in the
if i go to either fixed uh dimensional
settings or the sparks are high
dimensional right then all the summaries
will be other we can scale
and then if i take one of them
let's say this is my sum and one
um and let's say they get standard
deviation
right
um
so what do i get i have basically one
over root six times
and that's my standard deviation of the
positive right
these are supposed to match up
and this is what happens in the product
but i was trying to show that plot uh
one of the histograms was plucking this
with one of the selects
the other was just plotting the crossfit
and both were using
sure okay i think i understand
what i was trying to
get intuition for is why are the
covariance negative
the different
folds or whatever
you call here right so
that is when we used mles for both the
instances and we thought that some
universal phenomenon
and we thought that that should point to
the fact that you know prospecting all
this helps like to get even more
variance reduction
but we have more simulations with other
news estimators now where we don't see
it negative anymore we just see these
are different
so we don't yet understand
we see that the
covariances are nonzero it doesn't scale
synthetically they survive but
i have to come back with an answer in
like two months like when they are
negative and when they are positive
because initially we thought we were
actually like
there is something more going on with
prospecting and that it has further
benefits in this regime and you see that
when you do things like mle which are
unregularized so you shouldn't actually
be doing that surprisingly kind of helps
you with the variance eventually which
is nice but then if you do like
regularized things they really start
seeing like other things so
so yeah so so i don't know if that is
there i mean for the mle it's there but
that's also i think because everybody's
backwards
all of us don't have an analogy for
cross-validation right oh yeah yeah yeah
i think so so i started thinking about
the cross-validation problem after kind
of finishing this and i'm like hey this
is like what you would expect in
consolidation also
um and also like the akshat three was
sort of a plot
[Music]
but yeah that's all of this
i think they the analysis should be
similar
oh yeah i'll be happy to talk with you
okay i think we should uh thank you and
that concludes today
you